our next talk is
we will talk about his journey with
Earth
thank you
well thanks for the invitation actually
to speak and this is a great opportunity
and I'm a bit actually uh
let's see how it goes so
uh so actually you can you can look
actually here and this is a picture
which is uh you may be guessing how old
it is so it's like almost 20 years ago
actually so
um okay so so I'm going to talk about
actually some parts of Eric's work which
we didn't hear much about so I'm not
going to
mention the keyboard here
and uh as I am going to talk about I
think a passion which we both have share
we started again that steering machines
and circuits so let me just start by
Turing machines so so when I say turing
machine I actually sing the waste like
this and uh I hope everyone knows what
tuning machine is and we can think of by
a different variants based you know like
uh you know deterministic or
non-domestic or probabilistic and I will
actually first actually talk about none
of the massive ones so when we are
talking of another basic Turing machines
or non-domestic computation we usually
single for this uh computation tree so
you've got your input X and somehow the
machine the machine starts to compute
and there are like this diverging Paths
of the computation that we think of and
usually when we when we want to say that
the machine accepts then we we have this
accepting notes and at least one of the
nodes has to be accepting for for the
input to be accepted
and of course there is a there is a big
open problem actually if I give you a
language which is uh not recognized by a
non-derministic machine can we actually
recognize it by uh what we call common
domestic machines or can we actually
flip the acceptance conditions uh you
know so is there a machine so for each
machine M if it's a running say in
polymer time so we measure the time by
the length of the computation and for
each language in NP is there uh you know
we know that X is in L if and only if
there is some accepting computation or
not input and we would like to be some
other machine M Prime here which would
also run in polymer time and it will
have the opposite property so if x is in
the language there is no accepting
computation
and of course that's a big open problem
it's still open you don't know actually
what uh what's the outcome
but you can form my form I have actually
a bunch of other similar questions
actually about accepting uh computations
and one of them actually which is kind
of resolved is actually a so-called
analysis
anambiguous computation so uh so that
was the result by Valiant and here what
what the goal is actually I got a I got
a machine MH has the usual like MP
condition and I want to actually modify
it into a machine which actually has
exactly one unique path so if there are
originally was like multiple unit
multiple accepting paths now I want to
have just like single acceptance tasks
and this is the famous Valiant wazirame
result on isolation and they actually
show that basically there is uh there is
a reduction from from the from NP to
basically kind of what up uh so I I kind
of like put out quotation marks it may
not be exactly correct but uh let's
let's take it so that's basically what
they show and how you can think of it
actually you can think of it what they
really have is they have transformation
which takes a formula PSI and uh Maps it
to some form of PSI Prime so that if the
original formula was satisfable and now
we have unique satisfying assignment if
the former was unsatisfied but it's
still unsatisfied so that's what I
actually did and this reduction was
randomized and they actually produce
like a bunch of possibilities and one of
them actually has this problem
so that's uh that's actually NP uh now
uh but you can actually so this is this
was time bombardment but time-bound rate
actually uh computation so when you
actually stick the time but it's
actually fairly natural to also restrict
space and then we uh then we could talk
about like uh like uh like NP space but
uh usually what people focus on is
actually small complexity classes like
NL so in the class NL uh you have a
again like the computational domestic
computation and you want to actually you
want to accept it but each computation
actually runs in finest space in
logarithmic space so that's what I mean
by workspace and probably you all heard
about this amazing theorem of Imam and
celebsane from 87 which actually says
that that actually does the stuff which
we wanted to do for for NP uh and
Company it does it for actually NL so it
actually establishes that analyzing
document and it's done by this beautiful
technique of inductive counting and when
this game not actually people are trying
to apply this to various things and they
managed to put like a s like s72
question and things like that but that's
pretty much what they were like able to
do so around this time up until actually
yes oh so so what does it actually mean
what does it mean well it can take
actually what the result of actually of
a man ownership celebs and what it
actually does is that they have like
efficient reduction of uh of
connectivity program where you got you
are given a graph and you are giving to
what this is something any one who knows
whether there is a pass and the yes
instances are the ones where there is a
path so they have a efficient reduction
which actually turns it around so you
you get some graph G Prime and S Prime T
Prime and they surpass between smt if
and only if there is a pass between us
Prime T Prime so that's that's kind of
like mind-boggling how we can actually
do that but they they actually manage
and people try to do more stuff but as I
said they you know they pushed a little
bit but uh it uh but basically up until
results of Eric and Reinhardt actually
they you know they didn't like do the
real thing and I think this this was the
real thing so so the real thing was uh
that um Eric uh sarainab actually showed
that the analysts in
UL slash poly so that's uh that's uh
that's a very nice result and
um uh yeah so that's uh and here is Eric
actually showing where there is actually
you know I know
so that's actually below p
IC well one thing so so it's actually
the the reduction is actually again
slightly randomized so you need a little
bit of uh non-determinism uh for that so
actually like you need some RAM on my
device and
um uh I don't think actually it implies
it's all not even like in some bigger
sense
uh that's one thing the other thing is
that
uh yeah you could actually randomize
this one so so you can actually
randomize it are supposed to say
Valentine
um well that could also be perhaps it
randomized but this one I can be the
randomized under I would say standard uh
standard assumptions and also that
result actually is kind of able to
detect wrong advice so if you feed it
the wrong advice it actually kind of
tells you
find the two you get something like UL
is contained in co-ul blood quality yeah
but um is there is a known weather UL
equals to UL
uh well it's the same note so I would
like
[Applause]
so that's actually if you haven't read
the paper I encourage you to really read
it
and like it takes a graph it just like
perhaps multiple paths from s to T and
it turns that into graphic as just
single pumps and if there's no paths
then there is no pass so that's actually
the action dance
uh okay so so that's kind of Turing
machines not a domestic turing machine
so let's go back uh to to the
computation key and let's actually just
uh be looking and staring at the tree a
little bit and um people actually stand
at this and they actually generalize the
notion of conduct amazing and they
generalize it to alternating computation
so so far uh basically we have seen
determistic and monitoristic uh sorry
common on domestic computation that you
can kind of like mix and match so so
like alternating computation basically
like whenever you kind of are flipping a
coin it's one of the Misty coin you can
decide basically like kind of like the
acceptance conditions so whether boss
pass the way you flip actually should be
accepting or whether like just at least
one of them suffices so if the
existential means basically like at
least one of the paths should be
accepting and um which actually means
the subtree should be accepting and the
for all means actually boss the branches
should be accepting
and um
that's uh that's how you basically
Define alternating competition and you
can like have there like in your
computation she can have like various
various States and the states into doing
machines are basically labeled whether
they are like these existential or
Universal
so non-domestic computation corresponds
to completely completely basically
existential Universe corresponds to
Commander domestic
um okay so let's uh this kind of uh this
kind of looks like a circuit and uh
indeed actually it was all in 80s
actually basically postulated that this
corresponds to like circuits so uh you
can actually tweak uh alternating
machines and basically make out of them
circuits where uh what in some sense you
get like from the from the universal
modifiers you you get uh you get n Gates
and from the from this uh from these
guys from the from existential you get
uh you get actually or Gates and it's
kind of like a one-to-one correspondence
and people in 80 is actually available
looking at it and uh you know they also
noticed that it actually kind of works
higher up so if you look on polo
maharaki then you kind of get like
exponential size ac0 circuits
so
that was kind of uh known and then there
was this uh you know like another like
surprising Time by today uh so it
basically puts like whole polymer
hurricane basically kind of massages
into into computation which I think
roughly looks like this so you have you
have this polymer hierarchy where we are
just like have some fixed number of
layers of alternating layers between
existential and and um Universal
quantifier and then you can turn it into
a computation which is like a BPP at the
top and then you have these Polytech
amplifiers so the parenting commanding
fire is satisfied if like uh the number
of accepting passes is is odd otherwise
it's not satisfied bpps BPP like
operator is satisfied if like the
majority of the pass is accepting like
State majority
so that's uh that's basically what uh
taught a bit in 89. and um I think that
inspired actually Eric or at least he
says that in his paper that uh that
actually you can put like AC zero
respiratory into uh actually quasi
polynomial adapt to uh Circuit of this
form so you have like uh you have uh
here the parity and here are the end
Gates so that's uh that's actually uh
Eric's result from 89 and it actually
really again uses this this Duality
between circuits and alternating
computation so it's actually it's really
it's kind of like taking advantage of
that of course also it involves rasboros
malinsky so that that's uh that's kind
of like how how you would go about it
and uh right so this is uh this is what
we have it's a probabilistic circuit so
so you can actually make it into
deterministic by actually replacing the
gate by majority so you can actually
make it into threshold dep3 Circuit of
Quasi polynomial size
so that was that was in 89 and oops that
should have been Eric I don't know
[Music]
so now now this was actually gonna
extended by by Yao which who and by
bigger and Third Way so so they actually
extended it to all acc-0 so acc0 allows
you to do hands-force mod M gates for
fixed m
and you can actually transform any such
circuit into a circuit which is depth 2
circuit you get like uh at the top you
get a symmetric gate so symmetric means
that it just depends on the number of
inputs that are set to one and then at
the bottom we have these end Gates which
are kind of like uh fairly small so they
have like poly logarithmic Fanning and
um uh so so I actually I think made this
non-uniform and then the Beagle Tower we
actually uh actually made it uniform and
um
again actually uh you know we saw Eric
actually took advantage of this so uh so
that's actually another beautiful result
of Eric so in 94 he actually improved
that permanent doesn't have unit uniform
acc0 circuits of a sub-exponential size
so that's uh you know permanent that's
this uh Sharpie complete problem uh you
know Computing a permanent of Matrix and
uh again like the proof actually really
uses this Duality between the two
concepts actually between between the
computation tree and and the circuits
actually in in a very crucial way and
you can see here it is really happy
about the result
and another one's actually followed by
Eric by yet another result actually in
99 and he actually pushes this from ACC
0 to pc0 so tc0r majority Gates and
constant debts and that's uh that seems
to be like stronger class actually
and uh but the the band actually he gets
his uh weaker let's say like super like
quasi polynomial so so permanent doesn't
have poly polymer size circuit in tc0
uh
so I would say that it's like the
standard uniform at the deloc time
uniform interaction
uh so this is this means actually
uniform result so I will kind of like
back how does it compare to what we know
but let me actually just like you know
because that's probably running through
your head so how does it compare to Ram
so that I am in uh 2017-14 so he proved
this uh this uh breakthrough result that
Max doesn't have HCC zero circuits of
exponential size or sub-exponential size
and uh so how does it compare so so you
know Ryan has a bigger class next so
that's presumably a harder problem than
permanent so permanent is sitting in P
space so that's perhaps reaches in X or
Max space even bigger than that but the
difference is the really like the uh
Ryan's result actually works for
non-illiform circuits whereas Alex Works
only for uniform and if you don't know
how to actually extend the result to pc0
so that's um so so this is gap between
HCC 0 and tc0 seems to be in at least in
with respect to our techniques actually
actually big so Alex is still happening
you know
tc0 yeah
so so why so why was the the previous
results
parity is inside tc0
uh and that's actually okay so maybe so
the point is that this is a website
action this reduces the depth of the
circuit to three wires
so you take arbitrary kind of like fixed
depth circuit and you just wash it oh
it's the three yeah
otherwise it would be like General yeah
thanks
okay so so that the service this bullet
between actually
circuits and acceptance trees actually
serves us uh
uh as uh basically like it's helpful to
prove rubber bands so so kind of like to
appreciate more these uh let's actually
a little bit dig into this small circuit
process or or like uh this uh this area
around this uh small circuit or small
space programs so so we know that the
permanent is a Sharpie complete so
perhaps it's like a fairly complex
problem and the best Upper Mountain I
guess we have is like P space and uh
determinant that's on the other hand so
so you just want to complete detriment
of a matrix so so you know we both
everyone knows that is these are like
totally different problems
computationally but it turns out that
the terminal is really easy even in
terms of space so you can actually do uh
space in really small space you can
actually compute the terminal and
uh yeah so so it's it's a it's a it's
sitting in a class which is so called
sharp l so that's a number of accepting
uh computations of log space during
machine it's technically speaking it's
actually different of two functions like
that so it's like in gapel but think of
it basically like shark sharp l
and um and then her Shadow pilot if you
actually look on this class if you are
not used to it uh you may not know where
it actually sits in this circuit
hierarchy but it actually sits very low
so it's in NC nc3 so
yeah okay maybe
together so so uh NC NCI that's just a
binary ends and oral notes and uh
polymer size log I look to the eye depth
so this would be locked to The Cedars so
uh right so let me just give you like
simple argument at least that like lock
says sitting log space is sitting and in
nc2 and well you just uh like uh we have
seen that the complete problem for uh
for another domestic log space is
actually uh graph connect activity and
if you take an agency Sensi Matrix and
you want to compute its transitive
closure you can like multiply The Matrix
uh one by one so so basically like
multiplying two matrices over Boolean
summary that can be done like in nc1
that's a trivial exercise uh if you go
if you want to actually compute
connectivity then you know you just make
a three of these multiplications of
logarithmic depths and that's going to
give you nc2 so so nc2 is really like
encapsulating these small space classes
and um
that's why actually it is determinant is
actually very low in the complexity
and um
if we compare it back to what Eric
showed that he actually is showing that
this acc0 and tc0 doesn't actually
contain uh contain uh contain
determinant but uh but all these all
these actually things are also uniform
so so there is actually something so
he's actually saying something uh really
like a uh surviving so
uh so what do we know about small lab
circuits so uh so of course like the we
know that acc0 is contained in tc0 we
know tc0 is in C1 but it's still open
whether this class is actually somehow
are the same that they collapse so uh
for example we don't know where the
Paramount and the same uh uniform and C3
so that that's kind of open and that
would be I would say shocking actually
because it would mean that it's a it's
computable in a locks lock Cube space
so but we are unable to prove it in
order to terminal is there but we aren't
able to prove it both permanent
so so how can we actually go about like
proving these things well here is a
result which uh you have with Eric so uh
so it's actually turns out that you
don't have to prove like a crazy super
polynomial rubber bands actually to to
prove this the only thing you have to
prove is that basically you know
majority is not computable as cc0
circuits of size M31 plus Epsilon so in
particle what we prove is that if
majority is computed by cse0 circuits of
sample normal size then it's actually
computable by circuits of size and 2d1
plus Epsilon and you can actually make
similar Arguments for for actually other
for other for for although for pc0 with
respect to some and see non-complete
problems like for my evaluation and um
so if you can actually prove this into
the OnePlus Epsilon bounds rubber bounds
on
ACC 0 or tc0 circuits then you basically
won't
so I think this kind of like fed them
into this stream of magnification uh we
we call it like that but actually what's
really in what was actually surprising
to me like uh I guess like three or four
years back actually Vijay and uh Roy
actually showed actually kind of
improvement on this result and what they
showed is that this Epsilon is can be
replaced basically like one over Co C to
the D so like uh really like you need
like barely actually super linear uh
actually rubber bands so the D is the
depth of the circuit so over here this
Epsilon actually depending on the depths
of the circuit and the bigger the
circuit and the better lower mind you
would have to prove like one over D but
over here they got actually exponential
exponentially and this is uh this is
actually really close to lower bounds
which people know how to prove for
example for parity
so this is uh this is actually not
completely far-fetched that you could
prove those lower balls
options so uh you know so so we have
seen that uh kind of uh determinant is
in small space and so let's let's look
on other functions which are kind of
basic so uh you know like addition and
summation that's an easier exercise to
do it in ac0 and uh
uh then uh
you know like uh what next you could do
so what do I mean by audition you just
get two inputs X and Y most of them and
bit strings and you want to Output this
n plus one summation or subtraction
so so that's uh that's nice so how about
multiplication well actually
multiplication allows you to do parity
because that's an easy exercise so you
cannot put it in ac0 so you have to go
outside but if you go to pc0 then you
get like multiplication like uh very
easy
division well no uh division so division
actually is also in tc0 and that was
actually known since 80s But Eric with
uh with Dave Barrington and uh William
has they actually proved that actually
the circuits have been can be actually
made completely uniform and this is
actually very nice you know this came
out about the time and there was this
painting back you know or maybe the
panting back was like slightly after
when they actually had the problem with
division and it turns out that actually
really like uh the circuitry we have in
our computers actually use some
non-trivial algorithms to the division
so so indeed I think this is it may well
be that like one day actually Eric's
algorithm is going to run our computers
likely that around the same time they
were dubious claims about the gcd
problem what's the current status of the
GCB problem
I think it's still wide open the word
claims at the time I know
it's quite open to do anything better
than NC yeah
it's it's certainly probably time
computable we don't know any kind of
parallel yeah anything better than
animals
and the approach it was suggested is
completely floating in the aristic limit
or it's just that is there anything else
are there any informed projectors like
that that approach it was proposed these
flaws even as they receive the approach
that was in that paper by veto is dead
but um
[Music]
and there's this
Russo and um
I think Russo and Tampa
the paper where they
let me just point out actually this this
kind of came after a little state but I
think they will still do some back
actually today
uh the question is that it's not
conjecture given that that is in PC zero
it's conjecture that that is like the
the class of cooking right it's between
nc2 and nc1 right so can you actually
this prove this yeah
so that's kind of like so that goes back
to this permanent thing you know like uh
so proof however Islam
so that's cool so so so we have seen
actually like uh two techniques how to
build actually a circuit from uh from
pulling machines one of them was
actually looking on this tree of
alternating a computation and the other
one was actually this nc2 where we
actually upper bounded uh the size of
workspace actually and uh there is a
there is yet another way you probably
actually all know and that's uh that's
the danger Fisher uh result that if you
have uh d-time Tien uh tuning machine
computation then you can actually you
can actually turn it into a circuit of
size e n log DM and that's the n and
you know like usually I what I do is I
teach actually result that you can
actually do TM kind of TN squared where
you take this cook 11 basically Tableau
where each line actually corresponds to
corresponds to a corresponds to a line
of the computations just let's think of
one tape and and then every four every
four types in this in this kind of
configuration like ABC implies what D is
so you can easily like replace it by a
circuit and that gives you a circuit of
size t squared
and um of course so that that's kind of
like uh well lazy actually only recently
I've I found out that actually that uh
piping giant fish actually had like a
very simple construction so I'll let me
do this is the picture of their
construction actually uh which which
gives you USB the analog DM and uh
uh you know so so there's actually a lot
of questions you can ask about this
construction it's a it's a inductive
construction where you basically go from
circuit CM which kind of uh makes M
steps of computation uh into circuit c2m
which makes two amp steps of the
computation and it's just based on a
like very simple observation that if you
know where the head is then you can
shift it so that the circuit CM would
have it in a kind of reasonable uh
position and then you just so basically
we're just shifting and and uh
right right exactly it's also used there
but and this result is kind of at the
very end of the paper and nobody reads
that right right
well yeah except for Iron Man so so
basically the song so it's actually
really easy and you should learn it and
you should you should actually teach it
and um uh so so this rotation can be
done by a linear size device so you end
up with sexual inner sized uh like a
sorry you'll end up with circuits of
size and Morgan which actually kind of
make end steps of computation
um so so you get this uh depths uh Tien
log TN now the question is what do you
actually do you get something better if
you have actually unbounded uh circuit
so if you have unbedded fan name
circuits then you can actually reduce
the depth little bit while maintaining
the size so you can actually do like TN
over long log TN while keeping the size
the tier lock DN and you know if you go
to size t 10 to the OnePlus Epsilon then
you can actually you can actually do
depths like TN over login so you can
actually slightly reduce the depth if
you are if you have on money Gates
so of course there is a there is a big
question to me which I have found really
fascinating and that's actually can you
do better actually for for simulation of
Turing machines and I think this is like
great answer of mystery and maybe it's
actually hard in the general like
multitude model but how about if you
have just single taped tuning machine I
mean there ought to be something simpler
actually like something smaller and you
know I I would encourage young people to
actually think about this program
because that seems to be
um seems to be nice so I'm meeting the
end of my of my talk so so let me
actually just like push one problem
which I really like and that's uh
probably like all CS people should like
because that's sorting so in the Sorting
problem uh you probably know zillions of
algorithms but you get like an integers
and uh each integer is actually two log
n Bits each
and maybe you know this analog and
rubber band so let me just tell you
that's complete crap because that's
actually been in a larger bound because
the input has size and login so so I
don't know any super linear rubber band
and if you go to Turing machines you can
start in time and log Square
uh if you go to circuits you can sort in
size unlocks van and that's basically
like nc1 or something close to that
and can you do better actually
and uh well I think that this is a
really like kind of like a right to
proof ladder bands for and I'm kind of I
tried but I I didn't succeed but I would
uh you know it's a really nice problem
why is it actually a nice problem
because uh because you have uh it's
multi-output function so as opposed to
just Boolean function it's actually
where where you know it's just like you
have one bit of output and it's hard to
argue about it this actually gives you
like M inputs uh and and
you know M output so it's actually much
harder function just by definition and
yeah so one way to do this is maybe yeah
Overkill is to get to what you're claim
not to improve it is there's like a
linear size log Gap
um comparator Network
and then you could replace each
comparator
right and that stuff so but that gives
you exactly the size so that is that is
all that needed to get that instance if
you just do something right yeah books
actually you can do that and you can
like and square the desk looks bad or
something maybe a little bit less but
yeah
good so that's for the upper bounds but
for the rubber band actually the rubber
band would not actually break any
natural assumption you know we can build
like use whatever techniques you like
because it's it's really like modest
lava
so I think that is soon like even like
for nc1 circuits actually proving such
lower bound it's not known
uh so let me finish here so Eric is uh
Dancing Away
um
are there any questions
let's go crazy is that waltz or what is
that this is English dancing
but the occasion is Tuesday
a special English country dance ball
yeah I think it's uh known for actually
his uh dancing
uh Yes actually that's a good question
so so under Network coding you actually
can prove this assumption I suspect this
should probably be over two and I don't
actually think about it
under some assumptions actually people
try to prove like superlumeral rubber
bands on cooling machines like already
like in 70s
is
what is Network coding oh natural coding
that's uh that's uh Network coding is is
this problem uh when you want to
transmit like information from multiple
sources to multiple multiple
destinations and you have like a you
have a network where there are a
capacities on the edges and but like in
the individual notes you can do virus
computations so there is a there is this
standard example it kind of breaks the
intuition that you know
from
towards here one bit here and your
network looks like this
so so you wanna basically like uh cross
this across this notes and
um like there's some normal flow it
would be impossible but if you actually
consider information you just like stand
here A plus b
again over here with some B and over
here someday and you will recover you
recover everything so also the network
so this is called Network coding and um
Network only contextual basically says
that you cannot do much better than like
Network for Android
you can simulate sorting
algorithms
no but the network coding basically like
what the network coding is useful for
actually like this at this this
conjecture the network according
conjecture Coastline that this example
is kind of like
not happening under normal circumstances
so under that conjecture basically like
the computation just has to follow
normal rules and we can actually argue
you can argue about information
the first one like TM is that I'm like a
one take one
head model where we have like lower
bounds no oh no if you have one thing
then you can improve that you need like
that's great
[Music]
thanks
what about median
movies probably like on one type you can
prove that it requires license
I mean again it's no harder than so
right yeah
well for for median for binary inputs
it's just majority right
foreign